my name is diana and I am a mother
here your faith is in las vegas
thank you tell me a little about your
faith what do you do this and
more or less what you do here is your pc it
is a bus company that
has been
working for years  we go to parts nearby it is to
mexico yuta los angeles phoenix or
we have several transports to many
parts how many buses do you have here in
your prey here that leave depends on
the days but we have enough
buses that arrive and leave during
the week and work every day
tell me a little bit about the
coronavirus right now, how you are
working, you had to close the
business or how it turned around, in fact, since
it all started, we never closed, it
was always ours, it was good to work for
us,
if we have precautions, if we
disinfect the buses, good
guys  they have their own machine
inside here they have their 16 parts
that do it every day
if required  that they have masks to
get on the bus for the protection of the
passengers and everyone at the beginning if it was
not many people traveling that they had their
distance on the bus but since
everything is more or less calm then
people no longer care if they sit with
someone or whatever now everything is
calmer more better tell me a little about
the process obviously it takes a process
to make people feel more
comfortable you see more people who come who
are traveling how are the children traveling
the children or yes of course  at the beginning only
12 passengers the most they knew three
four or five and already the buses are
almost full to children alike if they
travel the same they have their masks
when they get on the bus it is a new life
no problem since it all started
you recommend them  something to the people
before getting on they have this pamphlet
signs or signs and here everything is
notified equally the temperature they are
checked to be sure and they feel
better they sa  see that they are fine or
the other passengers are fine some
problem they have had now that they
have opened well that you have been
open throughout the entire
coronavirus process but right now you have seen a
difference or things have continued better
no things have continued better  no no
we never have problems no more than if there
were fewer people at the beginning but there are already
many people who already travel and more who are no
longer afraid to travel and who
tells people what the reaction is not
because people at first friendly
talk to me  every day or I'm afraid to
travel I'm afraid to travel and they arrive at
a construction site and say no, well no, I see that
everything is fine and if they tell us don't be
afraid everything is normal we have never
stopped working thank god nothing
has happened yet  It is you, if you want
the rules, with what the
health and control center is saying here in Nevada,
who is telling you to take these
precautions, we have agents,
other different ones, work  They send us
information and that is how we can
tell passengers because sometimes they
have information that is not
true and we know
how to tell them what we understand they
expect for their business in the future right
now with the coronavirus that is
still going on  Well, let things get better and
hopefully everyone will continue traveling
and everything will continue as it is right now.